there's been this debate that's cropped
up in some recent years which is should
we repeal the 19th Amendment or not and
you know and he's having this debate
except for you it's mostly Ann Coulter
right it's mainly and but I brought it
up to Elisa and I I said the argument
that Anne is making is if we repeal the
19th Amendment she would lose her right
to vote but but the country overall
would vote in a better way right
statistically because the women would
vote for Dems but then there are these
other proposals what if what if we go
back to a time when it's only families
are voting you know only one family but
then I thought well that totally screws
us over because then all the single
people outnumber us and then they're
going to win all the elections but what
if it's quite the opposite what if it's
only single women lose the right to vote
and married women get I'm just like why
don't you just move on to the next
question because it's just a trap dude
it's just a trap okay